[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 en
France ce n'était finalement pas le
dernier conseil des ministres de ce
gouvernement sont porte-parole Gabriel
Attal a affirmé que l'équipe actuelle se
retrouverait la semaine prochaine avant
la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
pour le second quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron le prochain ou la prochaine
Premier ministre devrait être attachée à
la question sociale à la question
environnementale à la question
productive à affirmer Emmanuel Macron la
bataille pour les législatives néanmoins
lancées à gauche comme à droite les
manœuvres politiques commencent à 6
semaines du 1er tour du scrutin alors
quelles sont les stratégies des parties
et des différents leaders politiques on
va en parler avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés gens là la
Capelle bonsoir forte parole du
rassemblement national bienvenue à vous
en face de vous nous avons Stéphane
Troussel bonsoir à vous également
bienvenue dans le débat président du
département de Seine-Saint-Denis au
Parti socialiste Arnaud Benedetti
bonsoir professeur associé à
l'université Paris Sorbonne un
restaurant chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire auteur de comment sont
morts les politiques le grand malaise du
pouvoir et sauter éditions du Cerf
bienvenue à vous également en face de
vous Céline Calvez bonsoir vous êtes
député la République en marche des
Hauts-de-Seine avant de démarrer ce
débat je vous propose de faire un point
en images avec David Gilbert
qui reste qui sort l'arrivée du Conseil
des ministres ce jeudi était l'occasion
de faire des pronostics sur la
composition du prochain gouvernement les
membres actuels devraient en tout cas
être toujours présent la semaine
prochaine le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron ne s'achevant
officiellement que le 14 mai prochain
pas question donc de se démobiliser dans
cette dernière ligne droite le
gouvernement est à sa tâche pour
continuer à prendre les décisions
nécessaires pour la protection des
Français et sur tous les dossiers qui
sont évidemment les dossiers d'actualité
pour le gouvernement et pour le pays la
nomination d'un nouveau Premier ministre
va pourtant bien changer la donne les
spéculations vont bon train sur le ou la
successeur de Jean Castex la
personnalité choisie devra donner
l'impulsion voulue par Emmanuel Macron
en vue des législatives du mois de juin
en attendant le mot d'ordre reste le
même depuis la victoire du président
sortant dimanche dernier le choix qui a
été celui des Français qui est un choix
historique est un choix qui évidemment
nous oblige et nécessitent que des
décisions majeures soient prises des
décisions évidemment sur le fond mais
aussi
sur une nouvelle manière de gouverner de
faire participer les Français à la
décision de faire vivre la cité
la révolution politique promise en 2017
serait donc sur le point d'être mis en
oeuvre
elle pourrait débuter pendant la
première quinzaine de mai période
pendant laquelle devrait intervenir la
cérémonie d'investiture présidentielle
une calvaire je commence par vous parce
que vous êtes députés de la République
en marche le prochain chef du
gouvernement où la prochaine chef du
gouvernement devrait être attaché à la
question sociale à la question
environnementale à la question
productive quel est selon vous en fait
le profil idéal Clément Beaune parle
d'une femme vous avez parlé des trois
parties sur lequel doit s'appuyer ce
profil et donc oui ça peut être une
femme moi je le souhaiterais j'aimerais
bien que au poste de Premier ministre on
puisse avoir une femme mais ça marque
les esprits ça Marc les esprits parce
que en fait depuis Elite cresson on n'a
pas eu à se pose cela une femme et moi
je suis très attaché et on a pu le
porter au sein de l'Assemblée nationale
avec un renouvellement on a féminisé les
députés et c'est important et je pense
que grâce à ça on a pu s'attaquer à des
sujets comme la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes ou la prise
en compte de l'égalité dans les sphères
économique je pense que le la présence
de femmes qui étaient
issue des différentes couches de la
société il y a fortement contribué donc
il y a une impulsion mais comme vous
l'avez rappelé il y a trois priorités
qui sont celles de environnement du
social et du productif alors est-ce que
c'est derrière l'économie que j'en suis
sûr il va falloir trouver en tout cas ce
profil idéal c'est un profil idéal et je
rajouterais que ça s'inscrit aussi dans
une dynamique qui est celle des
législatives on doit avoir aussi un
meneur ou une meneuse d'équipe pas
seulement au gouvernementale mais celui
de la majorité de sa future majorité
Stéphane Troussel vous vous êtes
socialiste mais vous êtes favorable à un
accord avec les insoumis alors les
insoumis on sait que chez eux Jean-Luc
Mélenchon appelait à être à être
finalement le Premier ministre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon serait le meilleur profil pour
justement être devenir chef du
gouvernement en France moi je suis
favorable au rassemblement de la gauche
et des écologistes et je pense que sans
exclusive et donc je pense
qu'effectivement tout doit être fait
pour qu'il y ait une coalition la plus
large possible c'est le c'est dans
l'histoire de la gauche dans notre pays
le seul moyen pour la gauche de pouvoir
l'emporter quand chacune de ces
composantes se sont engagés se sont
respectés et même progresse à chaque
fois donc Premier ministre ce n'est pas
qu'un c'est pas exclu pour vous chacun
sait que dans une élection législative
il faut d'abord conquérir la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et que la règle
institutionnelle c'est que c'est le
groupe le plus important de la future
majorité qui
désigne choisit le Premier ministre je
rappelle quand même que c'est le
président de la République dans nos
institutions
je vous ai pas répondu à cette question
ce n'est pas le sujet non parce que
c'est pas le sujet le sujet d'abord
c'est de gagner et c'est de faire en
sorte que la gauche dans sa pluralité
elle est le maximum de députés élus et
pour ça le seul moyen d'y parvenir c'est
que la gauche elle soit diverses et que
elle s'appuie sur à la fois ses
résultats aux élections présidentielles
qui ont dit quelque chose et d'ailleurs
qui ont indiqué que la gauche pouvait
progresser mais surtout aussi sur ce qui
se passe dans des territoires sur des
implantations
de la gauche comme premier ministre ça
vous semblerait le bon choix si la la
majoritaire à ne pas Jean-Luc
mélenchonale oui ça sera logique ça
serait logique que le Président de la
République appelle une personnalité de
gauche si la gauche est majoritaire
enfin chacun sait bien qu'elle est
pourquoi les élections législatives ont
été placées à quelques semaines après
les élections présidentielles c'est
souvent tout le temps pour permettre au
président de la République et lui de
disposer d'une majorité mais si les
Français dans quelques semaines veulent
par exemple s'opposer à la retraite à 65
ans il vaudrait mieux qu'il vote à
gauche plutôt pour les députés de la
majorité une personne est de droite et
éventuellement
place mais on sort de cinq années et
d'un quinquennat de de sa cage social de
saignée fiscal de folle politique
migratoire de recul de la démocratie et
de recul du pouvoir d'achat donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour changer les
choses peu importe l'homme ou la femme
qui sera choisi ça
un premier tour des tables sur le profil
ce que nous souhaitons parce que nous
avons été qualifiés au second tour nous
avons recueilli 42% des suffrages second
tour 13,3 millions de français nous
avons été portés en tête dans tout
l'outre-mer et je remercie d'ailleurs
tous ces compatriotes qui ont voté pour
nous dans 30 départements en France dans
18000 communes donc à tous ceux qui ont
donné et accorder leur confiance à
Marine Le Pen ou leur disons maintenant
permettez-vous d'avoir un maximum de
députés à l'Assemblée nationale pour
pouvoir vous défendre contre notamment
la hauteur de 65 ans parce que je me
permets
vous avez quand même appelé à voter
Emmanuel Macron donc c'est vous qui
portez un stabilité de l'orientation de
5 ans si demain elle est appliqué
Emmanuel Macron devra donc juste pour
parler de ce choix du chef du
gouvernement en parler aussi à ceux qui
nous regardent à l'étranger c'est un
subtil équilibrage c'est pas facile de
trouver le le bon leader le bon chef de
gouvernement il y a une sacrée équation
politique à respecter si vous voulez ça
a été rappelé c'est-à-dire que ce chef
de gouvernement il va d'avoir pour il va
avoir pour première mission de mener la
bataille des législatives le Premier
ministre c'est le chef de la majorité
donc il faut qu'il soit en mesure
d'apporter une majorité au président
nouvellement élu alors c'est vrai que la
façon dont Emmanuel Macron s'est exprimé
à partir de ce triptyque environment
social et productif c'est plutôt
sémantiquement une orientation qui
plaiderait pour un premier ministre
venant disons du centre gauche ou de la
gauche sachant que qui plus est on a un
président de la République qui est quand
même pendant ce quinquennat n'a choisi
que des premiers ministres venant de la
droite c'est-à-dire Édouard Philippe et
le premier le premier Premier ministre
et ensuite Jean Castex c'est pas exclu
qui reprennent d'ailleurs quelqu'un de
droite c'est pas exclu sauf que sauf que
il y a un contexte politique avec une
j'allais dire une attente sociale très
forte qui s'est caractérisée à la fois
par le vote en faveur de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais aussi par le vote en
faveur de Marine Le Pen et jusqu'à
présent les signaux que semble envoyer
le président de la République mais le
président de la République a toujours
surpris sur le choix de ses premiers
ministres il fait son souvenir tous les
noms qui ont été cités en règle générale
depuis 5 ans sont des noms qui ont servi
de leur et qui n'ont pas été du tout les
noms qui ont été ensuite retenus par le
Président de la République donc je me
méfie de tous les noms qui sont cités à
ce stade parce que je me dis qu'il y en
a finalement aucun qui sortira du
chapeau parmi ceux qui sont cités mais
la réalité c'est que on pourrait penser
vraiment il faut être très très cru très
prudent qui dirait plutôt essayer de
rééquilibrer sur sa jambe gauche sachant
que en plus il peut considérer qu'il a
terminé le travail de fracturation de la
droite donc peut-être aujourd'hui
l'important pour lui c'est d'essayer de
fracturer à gauche c'est une Calvez
Emmanuel Macron dit vouloir changer de
méthode de gouvernement une pratique du
pouvoir donc moins vertical
éventuellement oui alors il y avait déjà
eu des évolutions de toute façon c'était
déjà la promesse d'en marche c'était de
remettre le citoyen au cœur de la vie
politique c'est moi c'est pour ça que je
me suis engagée on a bien vu dans durant
ce premier quinquennat qu'il a fallu
faire encore plus et notamment suite à
la crise des gilets jaunes quand on
ouvre le grand débat on ouvre en fait
une nouvelle pratique de démocratie on
ouvre aussi une
avec la convention citoyenne et là
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller encore plus
loin et notamment sur des sujets
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné malgré
ce débat malgré cette convention
citoyenne dont vous parlez s'il
l'affiche aujourd'hui c'est que ça n'a
pas fonctionné en fait si pour un lit
plus loin il le fait en plus sur sur
deux sujets qui sont majeurs qui sont la
santé et l'éducation l'éducation très
clairement c'est de dire on garde les
objectifs nationaux mais on sait très
bien qu'on ne peut pas faire la même
chose que l'on soit dans un quartier de
Cergy ou le président s'est rendu d'hier
on ne peut pas non plus se faire la même
chose en Haute-Savoie etc mais l'idée
c'est de donner plus de liberté aux
acteurs ça veut dire qu'il y a une autre
relation aussi avec les collectivités
locales ça s'est déjà vu dans la crise
sanitaire c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu
quand même même ça n'a pas été simple
parce qu'on était en période de crise
une relation entre l'État et
collectivités quand on le voyait au
niveau des centres de vaccination on a
pu aussi redécouvrir la façon dont ça
pouvait être fait donc cette méthode
elle est dans le prolongement il y a une
devant les urgences climatiques ou
démocratique voilà et bien l'idée c'est
encore plus loin d'inventer une façon de
faire une démocratie un peu plus
délibérative au fur et à mesure du
deuxième quinquennat Stéphane Roussel
vous seriez d'accord avec ça Laurent
Berger secrétaire général de la CFDT lui
propose d'en finir avec la gouvernance
je cite verticale archaïque il faut
l'invention collective d'un gouvernement
il est le projet c'est de mettre en
place une commission transpathie
transpartisanale ça serait ça en fait le
projet oui enfin sauf que dès le lundi
matin les ministres en exercice
d'Emmanuel Macron expliquer par exemple
que s'agissant de la retraite à 65 ans
il pourrait utiliser le 49-3 donc comme
signal de cette nouvelle méthode on fait
mieux donc vous savez les mots d'un
président de la République le soir où il
a été élu d'ailleurs il suffirait de
comparer avec ceux de 2017 ça
déclaration était sensiblement la même
qu'en 2017 et pourtant et bien il y a eu
la crise des gilets jaunes et pourtant
il y a eu cette négation des corps
intermédiaires les syndicats les
collectivités locales un parlement
disons-le très considérablement affaibli
avec très peu d'initiatives très peu de
propositions de loi le pouvoir
d'amendement des députés y compris ceux
de la majorité a été très largement avec
vous en cause
très largement mise en cause et donc moi
je ne vais pas me contenter des mots
d'un soir d'élection moi j'attendais ça
et puis surtout j'attends de savoir quel
est le projet que le Président de la
République vomit en œuvre parce que
j'entends bien qu'il nous disent depuis
quelques jours qu'il veut un premier
ministre avec une orientation sociale
productive environnementale mais en tout
cas il a présenté un projet politique
donc ces ministres eux aussi nous disent
que c'est celui-ci qui a été
victorieux de manière même je crois
qu'il y a un des chefs de la majorité
qui a parlé de victoire étincelante mais
pour quel projet pour le projet du
premier tour ou il est dit par exemple
qu'on veut faire travailler bénévénement
les allocataires du RSA on va faire le
président de la République veut faire la
retraite à 60 5 ans veut mettre en cause
peut-être nos éducation nationale
et je finis par là où est-ce qu'il
entend que dans les votes du deuxième
tour il y a tous ceux qui ont voulu
faire barrage à l'extrême droite dans
notre pays et faire en sorte que le
score de l'extrême droite soit le plus
bas possible dans notre pays compte tenu
de des attaques contre l'État de droit
contre nos concitoyens de de diverses
origines de confession musulmane que
mettait en cause l'extrême droite donc
il faut que le Président de la
République entende que dans son score du
deuxième tour bien c'est bien plus large
que les seuls électeurs du premier tour
sur cette façon cette volonté d'Emmanuel
Macron de changer la méthode du
gouvernement est-ce qu'effectivement la
pratique du pouvoir de ces cinq
dernières années était trop verticales
je sais pas s'il était vertical elle
était managériale clairement
c'est-à-dire que la verticalité c'est
quand même le pouvoir en majesté de De
Gaulle qui était très vertical là on
avait une forme de de gouvernance un peu
différente mais c'était en effet ça
apparaissait comme très vertical la
réalité c'est que si vous voulez
Emmanuel Macron a gouverné sans
implantation politique c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait sa victoire en 2017 est une
victoire tout à fait exceptionnelle dans
la mesure où c'est la première fois
qu'un homme sous la 5e République
parvient à se faire élire quasiment sans
appareil politique sans élut
territoriaux il loco et évidemment sans
député ou quasiment pratiquement aucun
parlementaire donc c'est une victoire
qui est tout à fait étonnante et qui en
effet et j'allais dire totalement
paradoxal dans le système
républicain français sous la Cinquième
République ensuite c'est vrai que les
reproches qui lui ont été fait c'était
un président qui n'aurait pas assez
disons discuter avec les corps
intermédiaires qui n'auraient pas assez
respecté des collectivités locales alors
l'exercice du grand débat est un
exercice quand même plutôt de
communication et moi je ne suis pas sûr
que du tout le grand débat et d'une
certaine manière calmer la crise des
gilets jaunes je pense que ce sont
d'autres éléments qui ont mis fin ont
donné la vie
sur la table qui a vraisemblablement là
aussi calmer un peu le jeu il si le fait
que les violences ont vraisemment
peut-être aussi démotiver une partie des
foules qui se mobilisaient à ce
moment-là contre le gouvernement mais en
effet aujourd'hui il faut que Emmanuel
Macron compte tenu de la fragilité du
pays la fracturation du pays retrouve un
autre mode de gouvernance ça c'est une
autre paire de manche parce que la vraie
question qui se pose pas partie
justement ce qu'on appelle la crise
démocratique justement aujourd'hui
Macron n'en est pas le responsable il en
est le syndrome c'est pas tout à fait
différent la crise démocratique elle
remonte à 25 ans ou 30 ans donc c'est un
processus très long mais c'est vrai que
avec Emmanuel Macron qui s'était fait
dire sur une promesse d'une certaine
manière et vous l'avez rappelé de
renouvellement de la vie politique
retisser à notre lien plus citoyen avec
la société manifestement cette promesse
en tout cas n'a pas été perçue comme
réussi pour l'instant
démocratique elle a été révélée par le
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui a
exprimé une colère pendant 18 mois lors
de ce dernier mais le Macron n'est pas
nouveau président de la République ça
fait cinq ans qu'on le voit gouv et on
voit bien qu'il gouverne en effet sans
aucune participation du peuple français
il dit je vais vous écouter je vais
gouverner différemment très bien mais on
a vu la loi avia c'est quand même pas
une belle illustration on l'a vu le Pass
vaccinal qui était finalement tout sauf
la liberté vaccinale qui aurait pu
laisser et appliquer au français et puis
surtout il a fait des promesses il avait
promis le le la proportionnelle lors de
sa campagne électorale de 2017
il a trahi puisque rien n'a été fait il
avait promis le référendum et elle a été
fait essayer de faire
non plus en fait il a fait beaucoup de
promesses soit démocratie il les a
jamais tenu donc j'ai aucune confiance
en lui il faut donc pour cela qu'il y a
contre-pouvoir et et je demande aux gens
d'aller voter d'aller voter pour les
jeunes s'ils veulent avoir un
contrebouvoir l'assemblée législatives
on voit bien sur ce plateau que la
bataille a commencé alors à gauche une
union populaire est-elle possible on
pose bien sûr la question et le
socialiste Pierre Jouvet affirme qu'il
n'y a pas de blocage sur mon table pour
François Hollande en revanche ça serait
la disparition du
socialiste on l'écoute ainsi que
clémentinottin et Julien Bayou personne
refuse de discuter le principe de la
discussion c'est le fondement même de ce
qu'elle doit être la gauche qui cherche
l'Union mais discuter n'est pas
disparaître et c'est une curieuse
manière qui savent j'ai été moi-même
premier secrétaire du Parti social quand
certains ne sont pas d'accord de leur
dire vous partez mais le premier rôle le
premier devoir d'un responsable
politique qui dirige une formation c'est
de rassembler d'abord les siens avant de
penser se rassembler avec d'autres on a
posé un acte qui crée de la dynamique
alors qu'il y aurait pu y avoir de la
désespérance qui donne un objectif en
jeu voilà ce qui peut se passer et pour
des millions de Français c'est concret
tiens là d'un seul coup on voit on se
dit oui si Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
premier ministre alors toute une série
de mesures que nous avons proposé pour
être être mise en oeuvre voilà c'est ça
l'objet c'est de d'être compris d'une
majorité de Français qui pourrait être
démobilisés à l'occasion des élections
législatives si c'est pour faire une
nouvelle union populaire ou quoi et bien
ça produira les mêmes effets nous nous
proposons une coalition c'est ça qu'on a
entendu
d'ajouter les offres politiques et donc
j'espère les électorats le 12 et 19 juin
il y a des élections législatives et si
on veut pas perdre 50 plus
vis-à-vis de l'inaction climatique que
nous promet Emmanuel Macron vis-à-vis de
la casse sociable aussi que représente
la réforme injuste des retraites à 65
ans et bien dans ce cas-là il faut des
bataillons de députés écologistes de
gauche insoumis socialiste communiste de
toutes les forces qui s'opposent à cette
à ce programme
donc à cette union populaire elle est
possible vous pensez à gauche en tout
cas ce que je crois c'est que les
discussions sont engagées et que il n'y
a pas de d'obstacle insurmontable
effectivement comme ça a été dit est-ce
que dit François Hollande ce serait la
disparition du Parti socialiste vous
êtes totalement opposé j'entends bien ce
que dit l'ancien président de la
République mais je rappelle quand même
que il est peut-être aujourd'hui le seul
président de la République de la 5ème
qui n'a pas été en situation de se
représenter donc peut-être qu'il a une
responsabilité par l'action qui a été la
sienne de la situation dans lequel dans
laquelle se trouve la gauche et
singulièrement le Parti socialiste donc
ça appelle cette situation chacun même
un ancien président de la République a
un peu d'humilité et un examen sur son
action en maths contenu de du désamour
il faut le dire du désamour des
catégories populaires de notre pays
vis-à-vis de la gauche et singulièrement
du Parti socialiste on l'a vu au premier
tour de cette élections
sur les réformes institutionnelles moi
je ne vais pas devenir insoumis parce
que sur les thèmes sur les sujets que
vous avez évoqués la question européenne
je suis un Européen convaincu sur les
questions internationales sur par
exemple un brûlant sujet d'actualité la
situation et le soutien que la France
doit apporter par exemple à l'Ukraine
donc oui nous avons pas du tout oui nous
avons logique là de soutien à l'Ukraine
par les armes oui nous avons oui nous
avons des différences parfois même des
divergences mais vous savez dans
l'histoire de la gauche il y en a eu
bien d'autres bien d'autres vous pensez
que lorsque François Mitterrand fait
rentrer des ministres communistes dans
son gouvernement en 81 pour faire la
retraite à 60 ans pour faire la semaine
de la cinquième semaine de congés payés
pour faire les 39 heures il n'y avait
pas des divergences donc il faut y
communisme entre un parti communiste qui
était aligné sur Moscou qui
soutenait l'invasion de de l'Afghanistan
et que sais-je encore et ça n'empêchait
pas en tout cas c'est ce que justement
ce que nous essayons de faire à travers
ces réunions
comment sur des propositions des projets
qui peuvent être différents nous
permettons de converger moi je crois
qu'il peut y avoir une dynamique
effectivement qui se crée parce que il y
a une attente très forte on l'a vu avant
les élections présidentielles quand les
électeurs puisque les appareils
politiques de gauche n'ont pas été
capables d'offrir un candidat une
candidate commun aux électeurs de gauche
et ben ils l'ont fait eux-mêmes par leur
vote utile le jour du premier tour pour
tenter de qualifier un candidat de
gauche au deuxième tour et éliminer
l'extrême droite du deuxième et donc oui
moi je veux que cette coalition
respectueuse
et générations de Benoît Hamon mais
c'est un accord dont on ne connaît pas
encore véritablement les détails aucune
précision pour l'instant mais c'est ça
que vous souhaitez en tout cas je
souhaite que ce soit possible dès lors
que c'est respectueux dès lors que nous
convergeons des corps dès lors que nous
assumons y compris des différences des
des programmatiques nous n'allons pas
nous n'étions tous d'accord on serait
dans la même formation politique et bien
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et donc
il fallait pas
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas ça qui
permettra à la gauche de ce pays de
gagner s'il y avait une absorption par
la gauche dans ce pays quand elle est
forte quand elle est à gauche la gauche
elle est forte dans ce pays quand elle
respecte ses différentes composantes et
qu'elle est pluriel Céline Calvez alors
il y a un certain nombre vraiment aussi
de politique de gauche qui ont rejoint
le mouvement de la République en marche
je pense aussi d'ailleurs à Jean-Pierre
Chevènement qui a fondé une sorte de
petit partie qui rejoint la République
en marche voilà mais en fait dès 2016 il
y avait eu aussi de nombreuses
personnalités de gauche qui avait
rejoint le mouvement d'Emmanuel Macron
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui je voulais
rebondir sur le la comparaison avec le
programme commun autour de François
Mitterrand là on a quelque chose de
commun plutôt autour de la personnalité
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc on n'est pas
du tout sur un rassemblement autour de
quelqu'un qui va se rapprocher du centre
on est sur l'extrême et donc ça va
vraiment sur une une voilà une mise en
place d'un bloc non pas qui se dit voilà
je pourrais être un blog qui regarde un
peu vers le centre mais vraiment vers
l'extrême donc on a le bloc de l'extrême
gauche le bloc de l'extrême droite qui
essaye d'attirer une partie de la gauche
ou de la droite c'est quand même assez
surprenant aujourd'hui quand on voit les
affiches de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Premier
ministre mais il va il va les décrocher
il va il va vous mettre sur sur la fiche
j'ai pas l'impression donc moi je dis
attention l'union de la gauche
n'oublions pas qui se doit pas être une
OPA justement de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
enfin bon ça c'est vous qui le
voyez-vous
ce qui me fait sourire parce que en
l'occurrence ce qui est sûr
que quand on regarde
nous rejoindre quand on regarde la carte
électorale il suffit de regarder
laquelle électorale je vous invite à le
faire vous verrez que toutes les toutes
les îles on va dire allez qui était
plutôt de droite qui était plutôt situé
si je regarde simplement la carte de
l'Île-de-France où je regarde les
arrondissements parisiens la réalité
c'est que l'électorat de droite il a
reconnu son champion il s'appelle
désormais Emmanuel Macron parce que là
Emmanuel Macron est en marche et elle
reconnaît depuis lui en tout cas pas les
électeurs madame regardez un petit peu
la cartographie des villes de gauche
va regarder les villes de gauche
regardez les arrondissements
pas ensemble on va parler justement de
la droite puisque vous en parlez
justement j'en ai la Capelle côté
rassemblement national quelle est la
stratégie pour les législatives vous
n'allez pas faire de liste vous avec
Éric Zemmour pourquoi
comme à chaque élection les châtives
nous présentons des candidats dans les
577 circonscriptions et nous allons nous
sommes enseigner encore demain puis
lundi prochain je pense que nous aurons
conclu ce travail d'investiture ceux qui
nous empêche pas de pouvoir quelquefois
soutenir des candidats qui ne sont pas
issus de neurones là on fait en 2017 en
soutenant Nicolas Dupont-Aignan en
soutenant et Ménard donc il peut y avoir
des exceptions elle se fuseront
de le trancher donc aujourd'hui
mais nous verrons nous verrons d'abord
si ces gens-là souhaitent également et
on verra si ne sollicite et si notre
soutien et puis ensuite cela se fera
aucun par cas mais nous pourrons
peut-être dès le premier tour peut-être
ne pas présenter les candidats sur cette
de cescription peut-être mais sinon
second tour
à la dernière minute je reparlerai quand
même que depuis 9 mois nous sommes de 9
mois nous sommes quand même son
adversaire il a tout fait pour
effacer éliminer Marine Le Pen et
l'Assemblée nationale c'est quand même
son objectif alors c'est un petit peu
facile aujourd'hui au moment où il a
besoin en effet du soutien du
rassemblement national de venir en
quelque sorte taper à la porte mais je
répète son tweet un poète nous ne
présentons pas de candidats face à
Marine Le Pen
Eric Ciotti et Nicolas Dupont-Aignan il
a truqué donc je vais quand même vous
donner les scores ces 4,1% sur Marine Le
Pen quand elle elle fait 45,2 au premier
tour donc vous imaginez que vous avez
bien compris que c'est quand même un
piège qui nous tend c'est que je vous
dites
pas un cadeau qu'il nous fait qui
présente la s'il veut être ridicule il
présente un candidat si vous voulez
Marine Le Pen elle sera élu largement
sur sa circonscription simplement je
répète pourquoi c'est un piège parce que
ça re diabolise Marine Le Pen non c'est
pas non mais non c'est pas ça qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'il attend que on
présente personne en face de lui nous
verrons bien je vous l'ai dit nous il y
a des instances qui sont la Commission
et le bureau et nous prendrons nos
responsabilités nous avons été nous
avons dans surtout plus de 300
circonscriptions nous sommes arrivés en
tête depuis 3 annéesions donc
aujourd'hui le chef de l'opposition et
de ce grand mouvement populaire c'est
Marine Le Pen est-ce qu'ils sont prêts à
le reconnaître et ils sont prêts à
reconnaître que Marine Le Pen et
aujourd'hui cette leader qui demain peut
incarner l'opposition et le
contre-pouvoir l'assemblée sont-ils
prêts à le faire moi j'ai entendu 20h15
Marine Le Pen dimanche soir qui tendait
la main et qui aurait les portes bien
évidemment à des ralliements et à des
ententes et j'ai entendu à 20h45
quelqu'un qui critiquait Marine Le Pen
et continue à mépriser je crois que ça
me paraîtrait paradoxal et que ça me
paraît pas la bonne méthode si on veut
demain trouver une alliance et
manifestement Éric Zemmour voulait
rassembler les droites il n'y est pas
parvenu est-ce que vous pouvez un peu
décrire justement à noter les
spectateurs vous qui êtes un peu
l'arbitre de ce plateau cette
décomposition politique en France parce
que finalement on a trois forces
politiques aujourd'hui donc une force du
centre enfin la République en marche une
force effectivement de gauche avec
justement à sa tête Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et une force rassemblement nationale
c'est un peu inédit en France et est-ce
que ça veut dire que c'est la fin des
parties traditionnelles ou qu'au
contraire parce qu'on sera quand même
dans des élections législatives le local
pour apprendre le dessus et qu'il y aura
peut-être une recomposition de LR et du
Parti socialiste cette élection
finalement présidentielle a renforcé la
décomposition qui a commencé dès 2017 et
on voit bien que si vous voulez
aujourd'hui vous avez plusieurs forces
qui
s'affrontent vous avez en effet les
vieilles forces de gouvernement qui
représentent si on rajoute aujourd'hui
madame Pécresse madame Hidalgo qui font
à peine plus de 5% au premier tour de
présidentielle c'est-à-dire que vous
voyez bien que même par rapport au score
qui était ce alors je pars surtout pour
les républicains puisque les
républicains François Fillon étaient à
20% madame Pécresse est à 4 et quelques
4,7 % les républicains ou pas parce que
le Sénat va rester les républicains ils
vont s'appuyer sur la force le Sénat aux
soins du second tour de l'élection
législative ne changera pas donc la
majorité restera aux mains des
républicains et de leurs alliés mais en
l'occurrence si vous voulez aujourd'hui
vous avez plusieurs scènes politiques
vous avez une scène nationale où vous
avez des forces politiques qui se sont
aujourd'hui clairement imposées qu'il
s'agisse d'Emmanuel Macron et finalement
de la coalition qu'il est en train
d'essayer de créer autour de lui vous
avez le rassemblement national qui
domine très nettement en tout cas pour
une partie à droite et puis vous avez en
effet la France insoumise ça ce sont les
forces politiques qu'on retrouvait déjà
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 mais qui ont
confirmé finalement leur implantation
politique sur la scène nationale et
c'est vrai que entre temps vous avez eu
des élections intermédiaires qui ont
confirmé la bonne implantation des
offres politiques de gouvernement qui
étaient les républicaines à côté et le
Parti socialiste de l'autre sauf que
force de constater que ces forces
politiques qui sont bien implantées
territorialement qui maille le
territoire de manière assez jaillir
efficace non pas réussi à dégager des
leaders et surtout n'ont pas réussi et
c'est ça le plus grave pour elle dégager
des lignes politiques qui soient claires
pour les électeurs clairement c'est vrai
que d'un côté Marine Le Pen de l'autre
Emmanuel Macron et de l'autre encore
Jean-Luc Mélenchon au moins ils ont un
avantage d'être lisible et d'être
audible pour une grande partie du corps
électoral et c'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière leur
force politique sur la scène nationale
et versement les trois forces politiques
qui se sont implantées au niveau
national non pas réussi leur
implantation ni la France insoumise ni
en marche ni le résultat au niveau local
ni dans les communes ni dans les lieux
je mettrai un petit bémol
sur la structure autour de trois pôles
on peut voir les choses différemment
aussi c'est la structure entre deux
pôles ce qu'on a vu en 2017 ce qu'on
avait en 2019 ce qu'on a vu encore là il
y a quelques jours c'est à dire le pôle
e-mail Macron qui est qu'on appelle le
pôle des modélistes et le pôle des
patriotes de l'autre côté qui est
incarné par Marine Le Pen et pourquoi je
dis cela et je reviens justement mais
vous savez très bien
Emmanuel Macron à partir du moment
il se discréditent il se dit il est dans
le système Macron vraiment il salit avec
le PS à partir
Emmanuel Macron ils sont tous la même
chose qui sera finalement très fier je
suis très fort la retraite à 65 ans
à mes électeurs dans mon canton vous
voyez les raisons pour lesquelles oui je
choisis je sais d'utiliser le bulletin
de voté manuel Macron contre Marine Le
Pen j'en suis effectivement très fier et
dès le 25 avril au matin je reprendrai
mon travail d'opposant parce que le
projet libéral de droite classique comme
mon caractérise dans notre pays la
retraite à 65 ans le fait de vouloir
faire travailler les bénévoles les
allocataires du RSA 20h par semaine ou
par mois je ne sais même plus vous avez
appelé et bien je vais combattrer ces
projets je les combattrai dans la rue je
les combattrai à l'Assemblée nationale
avec des députés mais en tout cas votre
projet
votre projet votre projet qui est tout
autant libéral parce que quand on veut
affaiblir la protection sociale quand on
veut diminuer les impôts des plus riches
quand on veut diminuer les impôts de
production ça s'appelle un projet
libéral à ce projet libéral vous vous y
ajoutez le racisme les discriminations
et les inégalités Céline Calvez alors un
point peut-être justement avec vous quel
j'ai perdu
mon j'ai perdu le fil avec votre
pas trop forte mais de force qu'est-ce
que je vous voulez vous poser comme une
question justement à vous oui sur le
scrutin parce que justement il faut tout
de même rappeler que ce scrutin
majoritaire donc aux élections
législatives favorisent effectivement en
plus dans le cadre du quinquennat le
celui qui vient d'être élu donc est-ce
que c'est là-dessus que vous misez
aujourd'hui face à cette composition
politique alors misez effectivement sur
le fait qu'il existe et qui a été vu que
dans la foulée de l'élection
présidentielle les Français souhaitent
en général qu'un pays soit bien gouverné
et qu'on retombe pas dans la quatrième
République et donc l'idée c'est de
pouvoir lui donner une majorité oui bah
forcément on mise dessus mais pas
seulement en fait on va faire campagne
aussi on va faire camp parce que cette
fois vous pouvez vous dire on risque de
perdre mais on est toujours en train de
se dire ça parce que si on considère que
tout est acquis c'est là où on paume
justement donc moi je considère que dans
quelques semaines on va pouvoir mener
campagne on va justement pouvoir
s'inspirer s'appuyer sur ce que vont
être la composition du gouvernement les
premiers gestes mais on va aussi pouvoir
s'appuyer sur votre bilan en tant que
député sortant de la façon dont on
perçoit aussi notre fonction parce qu'il
y a une grande confusion entre ce qui
est la fonction de parlementaire est-ce
que c'est vrai la fonction de député
enfin de de
souvent on est obligé de redire attendez
là ce le fait qu'il y ait pas eu de
cumul entre les mandats de mer et les
mandats députés ça a pu éclairer un
petit peu je pense qu'il faut encore
plus l'éclairer nous sommes des
représentants nationaux qui sommes élus
dans une circonscription on s'inspire de
cette circonscription pour faire notre
travail de voter les lois et de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
d'évaluer les politiques publiques mais
nous ne sommes pas là pour remplacer les
yeux locaux nous sommes là pour
travailler avec les élus locaux encore
faut-il qu'ils puissent ouvrir la porte
qui est donc
la conclusion justement de ces
différents rôles et bien la conclusion
c'est de dire que nous sommes là pour
soutenir l'action du Président de la
République et donc dans et de bien
rappeler quel est notre rôle au sein de
l'assemblée de leur équation alors
l'équation pour justement que vous
concerne qui concerne Emmanuel pas trop
l'équation Édouard Philippe par exemple
Edouard Philippe avec ce parti horizon
on ne sait pas très bien où il va se
placer donc il va se placer en support
de d'Emmanuel Macron puisque dès
septembre il a dit qu'il soutenait la
candidature la future candidature
d'Emmanuel Macron donc il se pose pas
d'ambiguïté là-dessus mais il y a pas
d'ambiguïté mais bien sûr que si Edward
Philippe il veut créer un mouvement lui
donner des assises il voudra lui donner
des députés on est capable nous dans
notre majorité d'avoir montré qu'on est
capable avec trois parties trois groupes
parlementaires d'assurer la majorité
donc cette majorité elle peut être
plurielle mais il faut qu'elle soit
forte pour que l'on puisse dans
l'urgence mais aussi dans la
concertation délivrer le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron
législative est tout à fait singulière
parce que c'est la première fois qu'on a
une élection législative depuis le
quinquennat où vous avez une majorité de
nos compritriotes qui sondages après
sondage nous disent qu'il souhaite
imposer une cohabitation au président de
la République alors ça c'est une réalité
qu'on a pu mesurer mais le problème
c'est qu'il faut trouver l'offre
politique qui permette un moment donné
d'un quarté d'incarner ce sentiment
alors moi je vois quatre hypothèses
finalement au soir du second tour des
élections excitatives premier hypothèse
en effet il y a une majorité absolue
pour le président de la République dire
que c'est la logique c'est la logique
politique que la logique
institutionnelle peut bien évidemment
affirmer deuxième hypothèse en effet la
gauche réussit son pari c'est-à-dire ici
le Paris qui est lancé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est-à-dire d'imposer une
cohabitation à ce stade ça me paraît un
peu compliqué parce que les projections
montrent que dans l'état actuel des
rapports de force on voit pas trop
comment la gauche peut réussir ce pari
quoique il faut se souvenir qu'en 1997
il faut se souvenir qu'en 1997 quand le
président de la République dissout
l'Assemblée nationale personne ne pense
que Lionel Jospin quelques semaines plus
tard sera son premier ministre donc il
faut rester prudent il y a une troisième
hypothèse c'est la majorité relative
c'est ce qui s'est passé en 1988 il faut
s'en souvenir François Mitterrand réélu
obtient une majorité relative il fait
l'ouverture il débauche à certaines
ombres de de personnalités politiques
triste il n'y a pas d'accord d'appareils
bien au contraire puisque l'UDF et le
UDF reste dans l'opposition mais il y a
une une ouverture quatrième hypothèse
qu'il ne faut pas totalement exclure
c'est qu'on se retrouve sans majorité au
soir du second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et là on se retrouve dans
une configuration totalement inédite
c'est-à-dire que vous avez une cinquième
république qui se transforme en 4e
République c'est-à-dire sans gouvernable
avec ça devient en tout cas il faudra
non ça veut dire qu'il faudra des
accords ça voudra ça veut dire qu'il
faudra des accords et là ce qui sera
très intéressant ça sera de voir par
exemple ce que fera ce qui restera du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale quelle
sera la position de ce groupe par
rapport à la à la par rapport à Emmanuel
Macron et à sa potentiel majorité
ce sont les différents scénariés qui
peuvent en effet arriver ça alors il
faut que les Français comprennent que on
peut pas laisser tous les pouvoirs tous
les plats pouvoirs Emmanuel Macron donc
il faut en effet qui a un contre-pouvoir
à son national je veux juste rebondir ce
que vous disiez cher Monsieur mais
au-delà des acquis sociaux que vous avez
pas que finalement vous ne protégez pas
au-delà de la catastrophe
il y a aussi aussi la dejorité on
connaît on connaît la complaisance de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour le
communitarisme pour les services
birdical pour le Woking pour la
régulation des clandestins sa mentalité
donc vous allez faire campagne pour la
retraite à 65 ans vous allez aller
convaincre les électeurs qu'il faut
passer à la retraite à 65 ans vous allez
faire campagne pour le travail forcé
pour les allocataires du RSA vous allez
faire campagne pour la réduction des
moyens des collectivités locales 10
milliards de moins pour les
collectivités locales comme ça semble
être annoncé dans un contexte où il faut
protéger les Français ou il faut faire
la transition écologique tout ça ne se
fera pas sans les collectivités locales
donc très bien fait campagne et le
projet contre projet et moi je vous
promets bien des surprises si c'est avec
ces axes là que vous allez essayer
d'obtenir une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale
quand vous parlez du RSA et du travail
forcé moi je parle je pense qu'il faut
renverser un petit peu l'obligation
aujourd'hui quand on dit que le RSA peut
être accompagné par les formations ou
des activités pour être immergé et donc
dans ce qui peut ensuite conduire au
travail c'est plutôt de créer une
obligation pour l'État d'accompagner
cela parce que aujourd'hui en fait ce
que l'on pouvait voir c'est qu'il y
avait une possibilité pour les
bénéficiaires du peut-être d'avoir une
formation parce que c'est pour toujours
pour les plus pauvres les obligations
mais quand vous faites des cadeaux
fiscaux au plus riches de notre pays et
ils ont besoin
juste terminé
très vite sur le RSA d'ensemble de ce
qui a été c'est caricatures nous on fera
campagne mais bien sûr et on expliquera
mais c'est ce qu'on l'a fait pendant ce
que vous allez faire campagne
présidentielle aussi on a compris
qu'il faut aller travailler jusqu'à 65
ans
pour lesquelles vous avez supprimé les
critères
origine sociale
62 ou 60 ans la retraite pour me
demander si je distingue les gens en
fonction de leur métier mais bien
évidemment parce que moi je veux qu'il
soit protégé
je voulais parler justement du je
voulais parler de la crise démocratique
vous voulez pas me répondre ça sera 62
ou 60 mais l'âge de la première fois
gauche première des choses c'est de
réintroduire les critères de pélicans
vous voulez pas me répondre c'est encore
négociation une dernière question Arnaud
Bénédicte 5 minutes Sylvain fort
l'ancienne plume d'Emmanuel Macron a
écrit la France à le souffle coupé la
démocratie française tente de survivre
dans un oxygène raréfié cette halte
démocratique est à son tout est devenu
est devenu un moment de crise est-ce
qu'on est vraiment dans un moment de
crise démocratique il y a 15 millions de
voix 14 millions d'abstentionnistes non
mais clairement aujourd'hui il y a une
défiance qui s'est installée entre une
grande partie de la société et ce que
l'on appelle la représentation politique
encore une fois ça ne date pas
d'Emmanuel Macron ça s'est renforcé en
effet ces dernières années ça c'est une
réalité il y a peut-être deux facteurs
qui expliquent aujourd'hui cette crise
démocratique des facteurs c'est que un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens
considèrent que finalement le pouvoir
n'est plus à Rome d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait ce qui
constituait l'étal-nation qui était
protecteur qui était redistributif qui
fabriquait l'avenir qui crée les grandes
politiques publiques et bien c'était à
Nation aujourd'hui il est dépassé par
des forces qui sont au-dessus de lui
c'est à dire que les décisions se
prennent ailleurs au niveau des grandes
instances internationales voir sur le
plan économique parfois chez les gars
femme ou dans d'autres grandes
structures donc cette démonétisation du
pouvoir crée déjà une crise j'allais
dire de presque une crise de foi au sens
quasi religieux surtout dans un pays
comme la France où c'est l'État qui a
fait la société donc ça c'est un premier
point deuxième point et c'est lié
d'ailleurs les deux sont liés c'est la
crise de la représentation c'est-à-dire
que alors justement cette
proportionnelle dont tout le monde parle
est-ce qu'effectivement il faudrait
finir par la mettre en place un peu plus
de proportionnelle à l'Assemblée
clairement aujourd'hui il a été c'est
que c'est vrai que un courant politique
qui part deux fois amène une de ses
candidats
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et qui n'a que 8 députés
il y a quand même un problème de
et la France insoumise 17 ce ne sont pas
les seuls courants politiques qui
aujourd'hui ont une faiblesse de
représentativité donc là en l'occurrence
il y a vraiment un travail effectué de
ce côté-là je suis pour avoir une pub
grande dose de proportionnelle elle est
pas encore faite et nous la ferons mais
ce que je constate par rapport à cette à
ce manque d'oxygénation de la vie
démocratique c'est aussi de constater et
de redire que le vote est peut changer
son quotidien c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on a on a eu mais
n'arrive pas à mettre convaincu ces 14
millions de personnes qui se sont
obtenues exemples et on a eu l'occasion
de l'aborder
quand on traverse une crise qui nous
arrive forcément d'autre part et la
crise sanitaire les décisions qui sont
prises par le chef de l'État elles ont
un impact sur notre quotidien elles ont
eu un impact parce que les gens ont pu
garder leur emploi et donc c'est de dire
que face à tout ce qui nous bouleverse
on a encore la possibilité de choisir
des dirigeants qui vont prendre les
décisions face à ces bouleversements du
monde donc moi je trouve que par rapport
à ce que l'on constatait dans les années
90 on disait de toute façon on a plus de
pouvoir sur rien le politique pouvait
rien faire etc aujourd'hui il y en a eu
une démonstration avec la crise
sanitaire ça s'est pas vu dans les urnes
malheureusement c'est pas vu dans ce que
j'ai aussi
qui revenait pas forcément pour voter
pour nous mais qui revenait et donc ils
ont peut-être pris goût au chemin du
vote j'espère qu'il reviendront mais
vous avez tenter des convaincre la
Capelle nous promet sa remorque bien
évidemment pour séduire leur électorat
pendant leur campagne et n'applique pas
cette promesse Emmanuel Macron je le
disais tout à l'heure à deux fois nous
l'avait formulé et je crois que c'est
une trahison qui est du peuple français
et ça l'est pas bien parce que nous
sommes en effet très mal représentés il
y a il y a un creux entre les instances
et le peuple français qui ne sent pas
écouter il faut une proportionnelle
intégrale elle existe dans certains pays
et on gouverne très bien ou alors une
dose de proportionnelle avec une prime
peut-être voilà une prime pour les c'est
arrivé en tête ça se fait pour les
élections régionales ce serait une
manière d'écouter les Français et de
respecter notamment les 42%. merci
Arnaud Benedetti merci Cécile Céline
Calvez et Merci à VOUS Stéphane Roussel
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
vous restez avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]